dans un entretien nos confrères elle
revient sur la crise des retraites et
indique qu'elle recevra les syndicats
mardi et mercredi réaction ce que je
vais dire à la première ministre c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas de retour à la
normale si cette réforme n'est pas
abandonnée la défiance elle est
extrêmement profonde les salariés ne
tourneront pas la page j'entends pardon
qu'à Elisabeth de Gaulle Elizabeth borne
de gauche et que c'est comme ça c'est
pour ça qu'elle reste
j'aimerais voir la partie de gauche
d'Elizabeth Zante parce que pour
l'instant je ne suis en face de observer
sur le deux poids de mesure
comment Zemmour se fait agresser il a un
appel immédiat du chef de l'État le
maire de Saint-Brévin envoie des appels
au secours pendant des mois et des mois
il n'a aucun soutien des pouvoirs
publics et de l'état grande
responsabilité de ceux qui ont attisé
la haine la querelle sur le projet qui
était porté par semaine et par ce
conseil municipal dans sa vie j'entends
monsieur Zemmour aujourd'hui nous
expliquer qu'il faut appeler à
l'apaisement quand il y a un mois ou
deux mois
il appelait à faire des manifestations
et à s'opposer à ce projet de façon très
élément en tout cas par la voix j'ai
déjà obtenu trois condamnations par la
justice de personnes qui me menaçaient
soit de morts soit de viol 3
on les connaît mais menaces on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir un centre d'études et un
centre de lutte il y a besoin on a
besoin d'avoir une mobilisation de
l'État qui protège ses élus c'est tout
je dis souvent le verbe précède les
actes c'est vrai que le rassemblement
national prospère sur la désespérance
sociale c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes extrêmement en
colère face au passage en force
d'Emmanuel Macron sur la réforme des
retraites parce que en faisant de la
sorte et en méprisant les syndicats
comme il le fait il ouvre un boulevard
au rassemblement national un an des
élections européennes le rassemblement
national serait le grand gagnant selon
une enquête réalisée parifopi du ciel
pour le JDD Sud Radio pour une liste
conduite par Jordan Bardella le parti
pourra atteindre 25% des voix la
violence et la violence
qu'elle soit extrême gauche ou d’extrême
droite ou d'extrême centre qui vous
permettez cette expression jamais
n'accepter la violence il y a pas une
bonne et une mauvaise violence le parti
présidentiel lui pâtit dans votre de
sanction avec 19% dans tension de vote
et 22% en cas de gauche unique
rassemblement national n'a jamais été
aussi proche du pouvoir qu'aujourd'hui
ça c'est extrêmement grave c'est très
inquiétant on est une extrême droite
c'est dans le pays le groupe d'extrême
droite Action française a finalement
défilé ce matin pour rendre hommage à
Jeanne d'Arc la manifestation du
mouvement royaliste avait d'abord été
interdite par la Préfecture de Police
Gérald Darmanin il navigue à vue
c'est-à-dire que un coup il laisse un
coup il laisse pas un coup il dit que et
Marine Le Pen est trop molle et de
l'autre côté il veut interdire enfin on
sait pas où on sait pas quelle est sa
politique le secrétaire général de
l'Action française nous le confiait pour
eux c'est une victoire et on a parlé de
leur mobilisation pour lui Darmanin
Gérald Darmanin a été
désavoué le racisme aujourd'hui n'est
plus con damné comme il devrait l'être
on n'est pas condamné comme une devrait
l'être parce que je sais pas si
d'ailleurs à une époque il l'avait
réellement été en revanche de manière
générale interdire toutes les opinions
qui sont différentes des vôtres par
contre c'est un comportement qui est
dictatorial et qui est dangereux et je
pense qu'il ne sait très très bien c'est
de la gomme et sociétés
grâce à la chanteuse Laurine qui devient
la première femme à être doublement
sacrée championne du concours qu'elle
avait déjà remporté en 2012 ce
sous-marin de 30 mètres de long
naviguait juste en dessous de la surface
des eaux plein à ras bord de cocaïne
les militaires colombiens en ont extrait
trois tonnes mardi sur la côte ouest du
pays Turquie c'est jour de vote après 20
ans de pouvoir
Erdogan va-t-il céder sa place là et la
question il fait face à un candidat
social démocrate et laïque images
saisissante ce jour-là
ils sont un sous-marin par les Marines
américains
[Musique]
depuis 30 ans 228 navires de ce type ont
été interceptés classement qui semble
avoir un peu agacé Lazare regardez vous
me dites que ce que vous en pensez
regardez le geste qu'elle le l'effectue
voilà pas un geste qui négatif au
contraire c'est juste un geste déception
qu'on utilise entre amis après je peux
comprendre que à outre-mer ce soit
considéré comme un objet